I have been chosen to present the award  for the best achievement in film editing  you will note for this occasion I am  wearing white gloves you will naturally  assume this is because film editors wear  white gloves while working you will be  wrong I am wearing white gloves because  the last time I was out here the person  bringing out the academy award was very  nervous and I had to carry him offstage  and that's why I'm wearing white gloves  the nominees  our Frank Pete Keller four bullet  Roberts wink Maury Weintraub and  Williams sands for funny girl  Frank rock for The Odd Couple Ralph  Kempelen for Oliver and Fred feitshans  and Eve Newman for wild in the streets  the winner is in the envelope Frank P  Caliph of Allah  thank you all very much and my special  thanks to our director Peter Yates and  all the other talented people that made  bullet